Trascrizione: Alessia Giorgiutti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno.
Ho deciso di iniziare con questa slide
perché mi dà la sensazione del tempo,
che ci investe costantemente
e trasforma il nostro presente in passato.
Quello che io sto dicendo
in questo momento
se l'è già portato via la corrente.
Io sono un appassionato
di film di fantascienza:
mi piace l'idea
di poter modificare il tempo,
di tirarlo, accorciarlo.
Però, purtroppo,
noi questo non possiamo farlo.
Siamo però da millenni [impegnati] -
e negli ultimi 100 anni,
diventati davvero molto bravi -
a misurarlo.
La misura del tempo, se ci pensate,
fa parte della nostra vita
di tutti i giorni:
dagli appuntamenti
ai sistemi di geolocalizzazione,
che funzionano ovviamente con il tempo.
Poi lasciamo stare il capitolo "mappe",
che potrebbero anche
non portarvi dove volete.
Lo possiamo considerare
un metronomo assoluto della nostra vita.
Non ha religioni, non ha confini,
ma ci posiziona perfettamente
nel nostro fiume del tempo,
che sia una posizione presente,
passata o futura.
A differenza del regno animale,
noi umani viviamo dipendendo dal tempo.
Vi faccio un esempio:
alla vostra sinistra
c'è la mia radiosveglia,
radiocontrollata;
alla vostra destra, la mia gatta Daisy -
non è venuta benissimo,
perché tutte le volte
che cercavo di fare la foto
veniva ad annusare l'obiettivo.
Entrambe mi svegliano
tutti i giorni alla stessa ora:
mi dimenticassi di mettere la sveglia,
ci penserebbe Daisy.
Per spegnere la sveglia,
premo un pulsante;
per far smettere Daisy,
e vi assicuro che sa essere
veramente antipatica,
devo darle da mangiare.
Quando c'è il cambio
da ora legale a ora solare,
la sveglia fa da sola;
Daisy, no.
Ci vogliono decine
di giorni, per regolarla.
Inoltre, ha un altro "difetto":
lei non distingue
i giorni della settimana
dal sabato e dalla domenica:
per lei tutti i giorni sono uguali,
quindi tutti i giorni
lei mi sveglia alla stessa ora.
Se il sabato o la domenica
volessi dormire un attimo di più,
lei verrebbe comunque a svegliarci.
Questo perché?
Perché vi faccio questo discorso?
Perché la misura del tempo
mi ha sempre affascinato.
Ha affascinato mio papà,
che l'ha trasmessa a me,
e poi anche a mio fratello.
Siamo una famiglia di orologiai,
e quindi io vi racconterò
un po' la nostra storia.
Quando parlo del mio mestiere,
l'immagine mentale che ha
la maggior parte delle persone
è proprio questa:
un banco da lavoro,
con diversi pezzi sparsi qua e là,
con una lucina, utensili antichi
e una persona anziana che lavora -
capelli bianchi,
perché l'anziano trasmette
saggezza, esperienza.
In realtà ci sono anche
tanti orologiai giovani,
e anche delle donne
che fanno questo mestiere;
e quelle che una volta erano le botteghe
si sono trasformate in laboratori.
Ecco, questa è la foto
di una delle aree del nostro laboratorio.
Noi la consideriamo l'"area pulita",
dove si fanno i montaggi,
dove c'è anche un'aria
purificata dalla polvere.
Come vedete,
il banco da lavoro è molto cambiato:
sono cambiati gli utensili,
ci sono computer dell'ultima generazione -
proprio specifici per il nostro lavoro.
E questo è un cambiamento
che ha portato vantaggio a tutti,
in particolare agli utenti finali.
Dovete pensare che papà
ha iniziato a lavorare a 16 anni,
in un periodo per l'orologeria
abbastanza importante -
quindi si è affacciato agli anni '50.
Importante perché, all'epoca,
l'orologiaio era colui
che costruiva gli orologi,
ma non esisteva in realtà
una figura di orologiaio riparatore.
C'erano per lo più
degli esperti di meccanica,
che facevano un po' di tutto:
riparavano gli orologi,
ma riparavano anche
le macchine fotografiche;
riparavano le pendole,
riparavano le macchine da cucire.
E spesso in contesti diversi,
anche perché i primi orologi
sono sì comparsi nelle orologerie;
ma anche nelle ottiche,
per via dell'attinenza
con gli strumenti di misura.
Pensate che i primi orologi
da polso da donna
sono comparsi a fine Ottocento,
inizio Novecento,
perché le donne non avevano il taschino.
Ed erano dei piccoli gioielli
da tenere al polso.
Per vedere gli orologi da polso sull'uomo
dobbiamo aspettare
la Prima Guerra Mondiale,
dove ovviamente, per esigenze di guerra,
non era possibile estrarli
dal taschino e vedere l'ora,
e quindi hanno incominciato
a metterlo al polso.
Immaginate i piloti d'aereo:
hanno la cloche, eccetera,
devono togliersi - impossibile.
Per incominciare a trovare
la produzione industriale, però,
dobbiamo aspettare la fine
del secondo conflitto.
Quindi il periodo storico degli anni '50
è stato un periodo un po' rivoluzionario:
incominciavano a produrre
i movimenti in serie.
E papà si è affacciato a questo mondo,
che lo ha sempre appassionato
e tutt'oggi lo appassiona,
con dei principi ben saldi
che sono un po' le colonne portanti
della nostra azienda.
E che continuiamo a mantenere tutt'oggi
e sono serviti per portare avanti
il nostro business.
Uno di questi è il concetto di pioniere.
Un pioniere è colui che scopre,
che investe in se stesso con coraggio,
che traccia i sentieri prima degli altri.
È lui che traccia il sentiero,
perché gli altri poi vengono dietro.
E lui, come anche altri orologiai,
ha incominciato a pensare di rapportarsi
con le fabbriche di orologi in Svizzera
per capire se c'era la possibilità
di creare sinergia
come orologiaio in zona,
ovviamente rapportandosi con delle aziende
che avevano incominciato a produrre,
ma che, sostanzialmente,
mai si sarebbero [immaginate]
di trovare degli orologiai
[già] disponibili a fare il servizio.
In molti casi, neanche
ci avevano mai pensato.
Dicevano:
Come mai iniziamo ora a vendere?
Cosa ci importa?".
In realtà è stato
proprio questo il periodo
in cui si sono tessuti i migliori rapporti
che a tutt'oggi noi manteniamo,
perché il servizio è parte fondamentale
di tutto quello che io ritengo
un cerchio che si deve chiudere.
Il produttore allunga
le mani sul territorio, con il servizio;
forma i tecnici;
questi offrono il servizio
ai clienti finali;
e la soddisfazione del servizio
permette di rafforzare il brand.
Quanti di voi si sono mai chiesti,
quando comprano qualcosa:
"Oddio, cosa mi succederà
se per caso si rompe?".
Perché io non voglio portare sfortuna,
effettivamente le cose
possono funzionare molto bene;
ma prima o poi qualcosa si rompe.
Per cui - non siamo eterni neanche noi.
Ed in questo contesto è riuscito a creare
uno dei presupposti principali
per la creazione della propria azienda.
Ovviamente questo è uno degli ingredienti.
Investire nella conoscenza.
Un principio secondo me fondamentale,
e dal mio punto di vista
va visto a 360 gradi.
Mi spiego.
Non necessariamente
nelle vostre competenze,
ma alimentando la vostra
voglia di conoscenza
e soprattutto il vostro sapere,
guardando oltre quello
che è il vostro lavoro.
A me è capitato spesso di fare questo,
di frequentare ad esempio dei corsi
che non sono attinenti
con il mio mestiere.
Vi svelo un segreto:
prima di essere orologiaio,
io ho studiato informatica.
E proprio il fatto di aver sviluppato
determinate attitudini di analisi
mi è molto servito in azienda
per pianificare proprio
i flussi di lavoro;
e irrobustire, soprattutto,
quello che era il lavoro
che aveva già iniziato papà.
Siate innovatori:
vabbè, uno dice,
parolona magica grandiosa.
Però l'innovazione
si fa anche con piccole cose.
Per esempio noi, quando io -
ovviamente io ho sempre vissuto
nel laboratorio di papà,
perché papà aveva il laboratorio
attinente la casa -
adesso abbiamo una sede nuova,
però è chiaro, alla fine
c'ero sempre in mezzo;
e bisogna tener conto che, all'inizio,
le riparazioni venivano gestite
con le buste scritte a mano
e il registro del carico e scarico.
Tutte procedure che funzionavano,
ma portavano via molto tempo.
Quindi abbiamo introdotto
dei processi di lavoro, dei workflow,
che ci permettono, attraverso barcode
e comunque l'utilizzo dell'informatica,
di non sottrarre tempo
a quello che facciamo meglio:
il nostro lavoro.
Non solo ho parlato del flusso
dell'ingresso e uscita dalle riparazioni,
ma ad esempio abbiamo
irrobustito un sistema
che permette di tenere
sempre informati i nostri clienti
sulla situazione delle riparazioni:
che manda degli SMS
se l'orologio è pronto;
che manda anche altri
se per caso si fossero dimenticati
di venirlo a prendere.
Ma non solo, per i "clienti business",
quelli che si rivolgono a noi,
dato che noi facciamo servizio
anche alle gioiellerie, per esempio -
c'è un portale
che permette di interagire con noi
24 ore su 24, sette giorni su sette,
anche quando noi non siamo al lavoro.
Questo perché?
Perché è fondamentale dare
il miglior servizio al cliente.
Sempre nello spirito dell'innovazione,
noi qualche anno fa abbiamo pensato
ad una nuova avventura imprenditoriale.
Ne parlavamo poco fa:
i corsi, la formazione.
Mio fratello ed io
abbiamo fatto dei corsi
di modellazione tridimensionale CAD,
e quindi abbiamo acquisito in azienda
delle stampanti 3D
e anche delle macchine -
delle frese tridimensionali,
quindi dei piccoli CNC.
Uno magari potrebbe dire:
"Sei un orologiaio,
a cosa ti servono questi mezzi?".
Invece sono stati fondamentali,
perché siamo in grado di costruirci
dei piccoli attrezzaggi -
lo facciamo in proprio -
e abbiamo anche creato
delle macchine che sono esclusive.
La nostra esperienza,
nel nostro lavoro -
Avendo a che fare con l'utenza,
noi siamo ovviamente affacciati
al pubblico, al cliente finale:
ascoltiamo le esigenze.
E questa esperienza
noi l'abbiamo anche riversata
in una nuova idea imprenditoriale.
Abbiamo creato una nostra linea di orologi
disegnati e progettati
da noi, creati da noi,
frutto della grande esperienza
che abbiamo acquisito con i clienti.
Chi mi diceva
"Non riesco a vedere bene l'ora
perché le lancette sono troppo piccole";
chi mi diceva "Non vedo la data",
che spesso quando consegniamo
gli orologi, mi dicono:
"Guardi, non metta la data: non la vedo".
Quindi questi sono stati
degli input importanti per noi.
Esperienza -
Vi racconto un aspetto:
ci sono dei clienti -
e una percentuale
neanche tanto esigua -
che sono soliti acquistare degli orologi
dalle prestazioni eccezionali,
tipo in grado di andare, non so,
a profondità abissali, incredibili;
oppure essere sottoposti
a campi magnetici molto forti,
urti, vibrazioni,
che poi sono soliti non usare
l'orologio in questi contesti,
perché hanno paura di rovinarlo.
Come se mi comprassi
un bellissimo fuoristrada,
ma avessi paura
di fare un vialetto sterrato.
Che cosa ci hanno dato questi clienti?
Ci hanno fatto intuire
che esiste una nicchia di mercato
dove manca un prodotto,
perché l'innovazione si fa anche
andando a colmare una nicchia di mercato
dove un prodotto manca.
Seguite le vostre passioni:
questa secondo me è la cosa
più importante in assoluto,
perché lo vedo in papà,
che per lui il lavoro
è stata una passione grandissima,
e anche sono emozionato nel dirlo,
anche noi figli lo seguiamo.
Seguire le vostre passioni è importante,
perché riuscirete a lavorare senza fatica.
Alimentate la fiammella
che sta accesa dentro di voi:
riuscirete veramente
a oltrepassare qualsiasi ostacolo.
Noi abbiamo fatto sempre tesoro
di questo modo di pensare
e, anno dopo anno,
ogni volta ci raggiunge una nuova idea,
se ne discute in azienda;
ed infatti stiamo in procinto,
proprio nella prossima settimana,
di lanciare anche un progetto
sulle piattaforme di crowdfunding.
Quello che posso dirvi oggi è:
siate pionieri e investite in conoscenza;
siate innovatori
e seguite le vostre passioni;
ma soprattutto, ricordatevi che il tempo
e la più grande risorsa
che vi è stata data.
E io, personalmente, vi auguro
di saperla consumare con saggezza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)